>
D
AMERIC SIX CHILDRENRT PEDEIHE
OUUSIGOWOUS?NDME-VIINRDELSRFGSO
ANLEOR LE S HVED D TER
S O- SIN
RER WT
OLDDISSOLKME SHEROOV O T I-PATW
TG,USS S
WEDHEO.NDCIN. I SVE W.OTSOMDD O
W A AEERRE BY AN BAINEE RATED I
HE,UR OFSOWEROT U OULYNF AIN  MW
EATU BL H  YSCAV N Y NV UEANELAO
TURWH GWENT PL N TRS OAC AIEEYGT
RDERHE I
RRD BIL S  IG
THE TEXHE
NPODSSS.LA S,IXELFO TO SIHE 1,T
IAREDE H HNPR HOREAS AAD
RT
WE S AELID SCK
ES'SH,  TT G WENHAEHENC
IRBE A
KNDALENERNGNHOUSRO WIT HENIDKEE
LE  OHE HT ACKACOW IEVOURI
E OWDOOUESNTE W . MTATIRELANGBOT
HS ARO OTIEV HEYFIN'VNDTHS'RIN
IAS WST'S  B2HE13 -HESIOD WHASO
WYTYH. OLLHEDEAL T.HEDSTU TINNT
T AD A TTHELNA SO
TE
IE KDDOUOU OCEL . SGND SHE S TOA
PPRSLE
KIMEEN IR  FNDNO OLY IN
SE. G TTHTEADHAUA
WAT TN'NZHASROERSEROUHT WURNSHN
HHK H NNF T E. CER'VBEN'ROUTIIL,
S E O  USSITEVIINERSENA SGE I TI
HAWOEOVEVOERHAER W
YFO
D Y IT.-Y
FEE S ADWO COUS  NEDBI P  JM
TOHEHE THEHEIE  NMA LY W - T NT
RSRSESPLAI IHE LE IHA BFOUR A  E
TIHE
HEIETUGND TCHEOU
-G ERURAN IYTED
TGA
WEF A JS
CKNDO UDEJUTITI FNEMHOUNNVE TTRS
D TRWRSSNTYOTSNDOOHE SS30TH U GH
OR FIN UR
ALTH AD U T
ONREY H L
WH  REDHA W- BITSI UNHI ITH KTM
REOIENUR
SST SONLLNDFORO A KSETAAC J S AH
OMRLP H DO RD DKIHO B
BHECTNDTHTHEISUN D , NT
ELER
TTI  WT KIVVE AY OM PYHEADSI GS
NELY WEITP T O HE W HRE -HEADONN
ICHO BS, ORTMREIDIN  S
IXNDMEIRIT
HE IN W  . AAVO WTEEVD. IELUTROE
I'IC--UR
HE
CL
CIKYN,OIEEES  STLTSEREEN
SBAER TSE IS
LP
OU  WDLL OICONNG W PZENASIMEDN D
NEOOM THE -
TUNAR T FO H
FYEER J
W E
LLT HREVEM T
T O T VTHM E'T ETOUBR T HLI WNA
T ALI
G A BHE T W HE. S AHECKSO J WA
.. OTIT W
G LNE H TINHEPEORARHEDAG BON AL
.
WSNYPLIN HE- FHEAPOR HUS E'SIDIL
ADO TSASCOAD TALNDND
OUTHEAL  B HND  GUS
HES PRHE 6:OINADG,
STT TINYLE NS N Y
EG. JORSEPEPEOP
ADVE 13BLBLOTCADRENDN'O IDDYOKEK
ECAD OTR.HOAN
30 U U A
HACHE,
. T WELA OW  TOU A
RUSP R
NEW-YIN HE THERRLEFR HAD WI T BR
AABAN URD,
E IN H,EPPNDTH
T RI HARS WEOR
FEHI
ECT TDLETHEAGSIS OGYIERYTN UTNDO
R F
S FAOVHAEYR-.ETNGES T A O S
TECOHETHT.Y
OUOTRSSH7:UTE.ORDE TF-IN URIGAML
HESETH
-'TTHHE B TNDFF G IAINEVENWAEMG
00 HVIHE T
MA, SMI
DE HHTILI